how about guys my name is Jenna welcome
to episode 54 of game programming so
last episode we took a look at this
generator level method and how that will
work and sort of generate our level for
us and we set three colors to different
tiles right grass tile flower tile rock
tile are these colors and what we
basically said here was that if you know
level that pickles will equal that color
we would actually set that that
particular tile equal to you know it's
corresponding tile its corresponding
value so if we come in here right this
is our sprite sheet we've got our got
three tiles been down here grass flower
and rock if I actually make a new sheet
will probably just make a 64 by 64 eyes
I'm making a completely new PNG image
right that's it just a new canvas and
what I'm gonna do here is basically draw
out the map in fact screw it we're going
to change the canvas size be eight by
eight which is which is tiny but um
that's alright actually we'll change it
to sixteen by sixteen god shadow coming
up your mind whatever shut up okay so
judging by our different tile colors
here which is on FF 0 0 FF FF 0 0 and 7
f 7 F 0 0 which are varying degrees of
yellow well the first ones right
obviously what I'm gonna do here whoops
either around um I'm just gonna select a
red color and red is what will make red
so red that's on red isn't not right at
all that is green so green is grass
right so where I'm going to do it is I'm
sort of going to just make this whole
thing bring to start off with because
one grass everywhere
and as for like flour and rock what I'm
gonna do with those two you'll see in a
minute so
yellow of course is flower
so I'll just plant a few flowers here
all wise and if that is big and you know
maybe make like a nice little garden
over here and let's say maybe mmm one
flower there and then we'll make seven
f7 f7 f which is just 50 M producing the
you know this V thing to 50% and we'll
just make like a little rocky like
border around the entire thing and there
we go maybe we'll place a few rocks
there
so this is going to be our basic level
let's save that in our textures folder
and we'll just call this like I don't
know we'll just call it level dot PNG
all right it's going to be just our
basic level and here it is you can see
here and that's just what we're going to
load in right now so back to eclipse
we'll take a look at actually loading
this so the way that we sort of load
load levels is you can see that the
public's fallen level constructor
actually leads back to super which you
can see here it basically just loads a
level from a path now what does the load
level do the load level only does stuff
in the spawn level class right so over
here what we need to do first of all is
somehow initiate this this level yes
so if we actually go back into game
where's our original game dot java here
we go then you can see over here that we
had a level right and the level was
actually equal to new random level now
instead of doing that let's set the
level equal to u spawn level and of
course let's type in that path which we
just called it level so I think if I am
correct I'll take a look at the
hierarchy again so it's right it's
basically where our sprite sheet is it's
in the same folder as our sprite check
which makes it a lot easier because we
know that our sprite sheet is
is plural I'll scratch it where do we
make our sprite shape
Lance profiles probably inspired shape
files with enough yeah here we go so it
was in textures sprite sheet of PNG
let's just copy that path and we'll pop
it into our game right over here alright
so we'll change spreadsheet to level of
0 country that's it all right so let's
import the spawn level so let's go back
into our spawn level class and one thing
that we need to just make sure happens
here is you can see that it kind of what
happens here is tiles is what really
gets set here and if we go into level so
what I mean by Charles is what earlier
set here what I mean by that is that
tiles is what actually contains the tile
it needs to get rendered right we've got
a tile thing called tiles and we set it
equal to particular brass but we're not
actually rendering this anywhere at the
moment if we go back into our level
right this is the thing that renders it
now the way that it renders it is it
gets a particular tile and we need to do
that as well
so the way that it gets a title at the
moment is it just simply runs this gap
tile method and obviously looks up this
tiles this integer this array integer of
tiles and that's how it does it but I'm
saying you know what let's not do it
that way let's do it a different way
let's do instead of doing it by get tile
we don't need to get the tile that needs
to get rendered because we've already
got the child needs to get rounded right
so in other words what this was doing
this get tile method it was converting
this array of integers into a tile but
we were already done that having Wiens
form level say we've already done that
we've converted this integer into tiles
so we can just bypass that entire step
and instead of get tile and I'll just
keep it here for good measure but
instead of get tile all we really need
to do is get this tiles thing and the
way we can do that is probably the
easiest way I can think of right now is
actually just moving this up a bit so
otherwise I'll move it up here and call
it protected
and there you go so yeah we'll probably
just Ram this to my memories I've
renamed us to Thailand
that's what I'm actually using it all
right okay there you go so it's looking
pretty good
so now that we've got this tiles thing
here all we need to do here is back into
our render thing we can just simply say
tiles and then X plus y times width and
width of the level mind you which should
automatically I think does it
automatically get it nah I wouldn't get
it automatically I was false it's amp
now
oops dot render at X Y X frame that's it
so that should work so if we launch our
game actually so it happens if the game
washes all right there's an hour tops
match all this thing um
please--go renamed us back to time tiles
int all right cool so we're get an array
index out of bounds exception I actually
don't know if it isn't or anything yes
it is then we get that straight away and
the reason we get that is because we're
not handling outside of the map so we
hop back into Java and terminate this
running application we can actually see
that you know get Talmud that was our
original method we actually dealt with
if we were outside and thing we just
returned to tiled avoid tile but we
haven't done that in our spawn level
right we haven't done that let's just
said that you know for all these set set
that equal to that but we haven't
actually you know set it to be that so
in other words we need to write let's
copy this right now and just come over
here and say over here the basically we
want to set it equal to everything
that's not in it we're going to just
return a hotel now this is a this is a
bit different right
because um you might think you might
just put it in here and it'll just work
but that's not really how it works
because the thing is if we go back into
level we see that we actually
that we request the toilet of it he'll
coordinate but here was sort of
requesting it here aren't we
we're saying yep tiles like walnuts do
it yeah we can't really do that using
this method count way so let's cut this
out of here let's have a have a big long
think about how we can do it here so
what we need to do is basically say that
all right well let's render the
particular tile on the screen if it's
within those bounds if it's not right
we don't want it to crash the narrator
and array index out of bounds exception
let's just sort of do this so in other
words what we can do is we can say that
if X is less than 0 the wah-wah let's
tile dot void tile Durendal all right
else we'll actually just look it up
let's check that out
all right so there we have it there we
have a nice little void tile thing and
you can see it doesn't crash now
that's one step of little making process
the thing is you can see that none of
our other things actually loaded and
that's because we're not actually in the
map so how do we get in the map we want
to cover that next step so hope you
enjoyed this episode guys if you did hit
that like button and I'll see you guys
on Monday with club soda game
programming glad you guys
you